what a beautiful moment to have with
with elliot and with vania
and i feel like those two characters
really understand each other because
they both know what it means to feel
forgotten
and ignored by their family but we
certainly haven't forgotten the
hargreaves family
the netflix hit the umbrella academy
returns for season 3 in 2022
but yesterday the cast including justin
h min and elia page
joined executive producer jeff king to
look back at some moments with the
characters in season two
with justin sharing his thoughts on one
of the biggest surprises of the season
we hadn't received the last few pages of
episode 10 yet so
i actually thought this was my last
scene of the show so
i really was saying goodbye to
vanya as a character but i was saying
goodbye to the show and
this experience and so uh there was just
a lot of emotions
uh that day you are so right the crew
to a person said when they read that
script because they hadn't got
episode 10. don't let ben die
there's literally an outpouring of that
kind of love yeah and it's it's funny
that
uh well i guess it's not funny it's sad
that we can't hug each other anymore
so that hug just means so much more in
retrospect with with everything
that has happened in our world and
another storyline that mirrored
present day was allison's involvement in
the civil rights movement a fight that
actress emmy raver lantman
is still fighting today i think the
unfortunate part is
that a lot of people like to think that
that was a really long time ago and that
time is separate from today
it actually was a lot easier than i
thought
to come to terms with and understand
what it could possibly have been like
for allison because i
experience systemic racism every day and
so do
so many americans and so do so many
people of color and marginalize people
and you know ruby bridges the first
black child to integrate an all-white
school is in her 60s she's younger than
my mom
it's not a distant past it's actually
really really
close and the issues of the civil rights
and the struggles of the civil rights
and the fight
of of the civil rights movement are
still being waged today and when talking
about their personal connection to their
own characters
the cast agreed that elliot page was the
least like his character on the show
i feel like elliott you're way happier
than
vanya
is quite quite quite sad most of the
time yeah
yeah i feel like i relate to vanya like
from years ago you know from certain
periods so i suppose yeah
now if you know the show you know that
the creators
love a good musical montage and during a
rapid fire moment
the cast shared the season 2 moments
that hit a high note with them all
was there a song that surprised you was
there a song that felt
either in character out of character for
the show was there
i really left the cover of hello i was
just gonna say that i really
was like when that came on i really was
just like genius that's it that was in a
different language right
yeah yeah oh yeah beautiful and of
course they also shared some updates on
season three with justin teasing fans
with the introduction of
sparrow ben and what it means for the
rest of the family
it's a different ben it's a very
different bend than the bend that we
we know we're getting a sense of maybe
not the nicest guy
and uh really sets us up for a really
exciting season three
what is one non-spoilery word that you
can use to describe season three
xpl
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
yeah there it is that could work there's
a lot in there to be dissected
yeah decode that you'll find the answer
to season three